(upbeat electronic music)
(piano tinkling)
- Wait.
(piano music)
Wait.
- Okay, thank you.
- Wait.
- Thank you.
- [Professor] Thank
you, thank you.
- [Piano Player] Wait.
- Thank you, thank you.
(dissonant piano music)
(clapping)
- Yeah, you did a thing.
- Thanks, it's just
a work in progress,
but I think it's pretty good.
- I thought it was great.
It was so much better than I've
ever seen Professor Rich do.
You just threw a cymbal at me.
- It's a fucking
tambourine, okay?
So, as we're talking
about music today,
who can tell me where
music comes from?
(laughing)
Oh, well, well, well, well.
If it isn't the two late guys.
I would've come up
with something funnier
if I had more time.
- We were at Professor
Leafminder's class.
That guy's amazing.
You know he speaks
forty different
Native American languages?
Yeah and he lets us go
into his sweat lodge.
- Oh, you mean a sauna and
anybody can make up languages.
(speaks gibberish)
That's a language.
Anyway, let's get
back to music, okay?
So, who can tell me
where music comes from?
- Professor Leafminder
plays 23 instruments.
- Yeah and he's got this
eagle's claw in his man bag.
- Oh wow, I didn't know that.
He's the greatest guy ever.
I'm gonna go over there
right now and suck his balls.
Yeah, he's the greatest!
- Check please.
- I'm Professor Rich,
expert in science.
These are my devoted students.
Together, with the
aid of harmless drugs,
we explore science's greatest
hypothetical questions.
(upbeat electronic music)
What if music dictates
evolution, underline.
What does that mean?
Is there music which
actually dictates
how we adapt and survive?
For example, what if the
prevalence of baroque music
made us more smart
or rap music brought
about more violence?
What do you think?
(sighs)
(mystical music)
What's this, a bird?
Native American Studies:
Your Kick Ass Spirit Guide
by Prof. Carmen Leafminder.
(sighs)
Son of a bitch.
(drumming)
- Let us be one with
coyote and roam the earth
on our paws.
(chanting)
(howling)
- Coyote!
(chanting)
- What a dick.
I had to examine
the roots of music
with an expert
who knew his shit.
How does the brain affect music?
I mean, you know, the
music affect brain?
How does music affect the brain?
You know what I mean.
- Uh, wow, okay.
Your ear, of course,
basically filters out
a bunch of vibrations
and produces a series of,
I guess, neuron,
you know, impulses.
- Right, like that song, I'm
Picking Up Good Vibrations.
- Yeah.
- What kind of behavioral
aspects does certain types
of music have?
- Well, I think at
a very primal level
music with a steady beat,
a regular steady beat,
there's a phenomenon
that, yes, like that.
There's a phenomenon
where we are, it appears,
predisposed to get in
sync with a regular beat.
You can think back to, you
know, working on the railroad,
right, you know.
- [Together] I've been
working on the railroad.
- Right.
- All the live long day.
I've been working
on the railroad
just to pass the time away.
Can't you hear the
whistle blowing.
That one.
- Right, it's a song
you sang while you were
working on the railroad.
What you were doing
was hammering spikes in
and it needed to be
done rhythmically.
- So, if you're saying
that that primordial beat
caused us to work and sort
of dictates our behavior,
would you say that music
actually dictates our evolution?
- Oh, I don't know.
I mean, most of the
hypotheses go the other way.
Music is what you might
call auditory cheesecake.
We need food to survive,
but nobody needs cheesecake
to survive.
- Perhaps music is cheese.
- Just cheese?
- We all need a slice of cheese.
I know I do before I go to bed
with a cheese.
(upbeat electronic music)
(mystical music)
- Sitting Bull turned
to the great skies
and said, "Give me a home
where the buffalo roam."
It is the call of
the ancient Sioux
when we ruled the earth
and played in the grass.
When we were just two.
(breathes deeply)
(chanting)
- Bullshit.
- Who said that?
- I did.
(gasps)
- Professor, this
isn't your class.
This is a different class.
I'm sorry noble one.
- I'll have you know
I am 1/75th Chippewa.
So, let's dance the
dance of the buffalo.
Tatonka, tatonka!
- [Group] Tatonka,
tatonka, tatonka.
- That's from
Dances with Wolves.
- [Group] Tatonka,
tatonka, tatonka, tatonka,
tatonka, tatonka,
tatonka, tatonka.
(creepy music)
- He's fine.
Just a few scratches.
- No, he's dead.
- Hey, did you see
Empire last night?
(guitar rock music)
- Now, first of all, I
want to congratulate you
on being inducted into the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
- Thank you.
- When you look at
Deep Purple now,
do you feel that music
has changed considerably?
- I think, technically,
it's changed from, you know,
let's just, for instance, take--
- Nickleback.
- Look at those chaps.
How good have they done?
- So, would you say
in many respects
that music dictates evolution?
- It won't change
evolution, but I think
it definitely has some purpose.
Glad to be a part of that.
For me, I was playing trombone,
nine and 10 years old.
I came home--
- Short pants.
- Short pants, black and white
TV in the corner of the room,
turn the TV on and I saw four
little chaps from Liverpool.
And I got the trombone out--
- Herman's Hermits.
- They're playing guitars
and I've got the trombone
and I'm going, what if
I held it down here?
And that moment,
unknowingly for me,
that was the moment
that the switch went on.
- This is even more special
because you turned a
trombone into a guitar
and that's magic.
(upbeat electronic music)
- I can't believe
he's really gone.
- I was gonna have his baby.
- Guys, I'm really.
What?
Guys, I'm really
sorry about this.
I guess if I were to put
it into a teaching moment,
I'd say, music
dictated his evolution
and he didn't survive.
(electronic music)
- Professor, while
you were undergoing
psychiatric evaluation,
the class got together
and made this music video.
- It sorta just
says how we feel.
- That's great.
Let's have a look.
Shall we?
♪ Fa fa fa fa fa fa fa
fa fa fa fuck is music
♪ What the fuck what the
fuck what the fuck is music
♪ What the fuck is music
♪ Note notes notes
notes notes notes notes
♪ A B F G B D flat
♪ Peanut butter jelly
peanut butter jelly
with a baseball bat
♪ Peanut butter jelly
peanut butter jelly
with a baseball bat
♪ Peanut butter jelly
peanut butter jelly
with a baseball bat
- Wow, that sucked.
Bye for now.
(upbeat electronic music)
(rhythmic tapping)